all right it is time for hatred mail as
a reminder hatred mail is the following
brace yourselves for the only
information that can successfully
penetrate a tinfoil hat Patriot Man
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay so hey tree at male is
patriots right in horrible messages to
me and then a professional deep voice
movie announcer guy does dramatic
readings of that hatred mail here's this
week's entry he's David Pakman also a
dreamer his parents and brought him to
us from a Hispanic country when he was
just child and has lived in the u.s.
ever since
Zionists and illegals is of even if it's
his real name did you give up on [ __ ]
Krim baat David Pakman should be
arrested I hope I did not pay for your
education I won my money back
deport ya I am an American citizen I am
an American citizen and everything I
have done that since my move to the
United States when I was just five years
old was legal and completely on the
record and you are too old to be a
dreamer I think I have to constantly
keep reminding people that you were just
barely a millennial I thought that
dreamers that there are dreamers close
to 40 now oh really oh yeah all this
ones were 26 listen it might have been
actually right-wing propaganda but I did
get an email from someone saying that
these aren't kids David some dreamers
are 37 years old and I have no idea if
that's actually true
well that's those to me but I don't
think you could possibly be a creme bot
with all the things you've been talking
about comes to Russia yeah I don't I
don't know how any of what was in this
atrium al could possibly be true you can
turn hatred mail into something good
because we have a coupon code hey tree
at 40 it'll work at david pakman.com
slash membership it'll save you 40% off
of memberships it is a big middle finger
to the hatreds